before we turn to covet can i
just ask you about the aftermath of the
pull-out from afghanistan um do you or
anyone else in government actually know
how many british citizens
are left in kabul or in afghanistan and
who want to get out
good morning
philip so trevor forgive me
of course the foreign secretary who is
traveling in the region and
is uh making sure that anyone who is
looking to get up who is either a uk
citizen or qualified uh to
have that uh ability uh for safe haven
in the united kingdom can do so uh and
as the foreign secretary said to the
uh foreign affairs select committee and
i know you've got tom tougenhart later
on on your program
that the numbers are in the low hundreds
uh the important thing to remember is
the evacuation
of 15 000
of people in a very short space of time
is a real tribute both to our armed
forces and of course to our foreign
office and ambassador uh specifically in
afghanistan who and his team did a
tremendous job
but we continue to make sure that
we hold the taliban to account in terms
of providing safe
routes out of the country for those who
are looking to leave the country and as
the foreign secretary has said it is in
the low hundreds
that we are still looking to
deliver safe haven for
all returnees who are uk citizens those
those
those few hundred of course are
if you like the most difficult cases we
know that many of them are actually
in hiding can you say anything obviously
without endangering their security about
what we're doing to ensure the the
evacuation
of those
frankly terrified people
well and you're quite right and i think
it's very important
that when we deal with such sensitive
cases
that some of the detail is clearly kept
confidential and i can assure you
that the foreign office
or the agencies
the ministry of defence are all engaged
to make sure that
those
people are able to get out as well as of
course uh the foreign secretary dominic
raab holding the taliban to account in
terms of
delivering that safe route out of the
country
for those who are looking to leave and
to return to the united kingdom
are you genuinely depending on the
taliban's goodwill
well i think holding the taliban to
account if
uh
that is what you mean then we have to
hold them to account
on this and i think the foreign
secretary is doing the right thing by
corralling um the both the the sort of
the neighboring countries uh and those
countries that have the greatest
influence over the taliban uh to make
sure that we
um
make sure that they deliver on their
promise that anyone who wants to leave
the country and has
a
country of safe haven to welcome them
like the united kingdom
is able to do so
all right let's let's turn to kobed now
which is uh your own territory we
understand that the joint committee uh
vaccines and immunization
has decided that
it can't recommend
that uh children between 12 and 15
should be
vaccinated yet
you and other ministers have decided to
ask the chief
medical officers of the four nations to
examine
whether you should ignore that advice so
so when did we all stop being guided by
the science
well actually that that is not factually
correct the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization has done a
brilliant job uh for us for me uh
throughout the pandemic
whether it be the prioritization if you
remember
they prioritized the most vulnerable to
serious infection and to hospitalization
and death and that turned out to be a
very good piece of advice so we listened
very carefully to jcbi
their latest deliberation on healthy
children and it's worth just reminding
your viewers that we have already been
taking the advice of the jcbi and
vaccinating young people 12 to 15 year
olds who are more vulnerable to serious
infection from covert so those who are
at a higher risk are already being
inoculated vaccinated as
per the advice
the jcvi
if you read their advice
on balance it is marginally more
beneficial to
vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds healthy 12
15 year olds is what they said but not
enough for them to recommend a
national vaccination program for healthy
12 to 15 year olds and they are the ones
who said that the chief medical officers
should look beyond what they are
qualified to look at so they looked at
things that they are qualified to look
at but they also recognize that there
are areas
that the chief medical officers chris
whittie and his fellow chief medical
officers in the devolve administrations
should look at in terms of uh the
vaccination of healthy 12 females
and that is exactly what they'll do now
we have not made any decisions so we
haven't uh to your question
decided not to listen to the experts on
the contrary all four ministers
so the secretary of state decided javid
and his fellow ministers
in the devolved administration have
agreed to ask the chief medical officers
to convene expert groups including the
jcbi being in that
to be able to recommend which way we
should go on healthy 12 to 15 year olds
but we are vaccinating those at highest
risk the 12 15 year olds at highest risk
we already are vaccinated thank you for
the i thank you for the explanation and
i understand it
completely
but
it sounds as though we understand you've
asked for that advice this week which
sounds to be frank like not like you
said
uh the jcvi said we need to make uh take
a look at this question in a wider
context and make some judgments
it looks a bit like what you've decided
is you don't like their non-advice and
you want some different advice quickly
why is it necessary in that context in
that sense to have a decision out of the
chief medical officers this week which
is what i understand you've asked for
so no i think it's worth just um
reiterating
that uh
the jcvi have said that it is marginally
more beneficial to vaccinate than not to
vaccinate but not enough to make a
national recommendation
but they've also been very clear to say
that
their decision is based on things that
they are qualified to look at and they
recognize that there are other factors
that could
harm uh the futures of children
and that is why they uh recommended that
medical officers look at this and then
the four ministers
the secretary of state and the uh
devolve
ministers asked the four chief medical
officers to look at this we're being
very careful
and all right right we have some of the
best clinicians in the world and i think
it's
that we um
just very quickly on this uh whatever
you decide
can you assure parents
that
if there is a decision to vaccinate 12
to 15 year olds it will require parental
consent
i can give that assurance absolutely
thank you now is it true as we're
hearing this morning that your boss mr
javid the secretary's state for health
and social care is going to require nhs
staff
to uh be vaccinated as a condition of
employment
so you you recall uh trevor that
when we consulted on the condition for
deployment of the social care workforce
of course we were looking after the most
vulnerable uh
people especially those in elderly care
homes who
clearly
covered took its toll on um that
consultation came back and we moved
forward on that issue but within that
constellation there was a very clear
feedback that we need to look at the
greater healthcare workforce including
the nhs frontline workforce so i have to
say uh and it's worth just putting on
the record one uh they have come forward
in
huge numbers to get themselves protected
and vaccinated i think it's over 94 of
frontline
healthcare workers have come forward
but i think it's only right and
responsible that
we look at the duty of care for health
care workers on the front line and
across the nhs who are looking after
people who when they're entering
hospital are vulnerable to infection and
that
you know we we consult and we will come
back and of course uh publish uh uh that
constitution in due course
that sounds really like a yes to me that
you are going to make it
a condition of employment unless you
find some reason
some compelling reason not to do so
well i think i think
the right thing to do is to consult and
then
publish that and then return to your
program and explain uh what
the consultation outcome is and then
therefore what decision we make as we
did with the social care workforce
all right well we're going to come to
the social care question now look
winter's coming
school's back you've got some big
decisions to make and i i'd like to
gallop through uh
two or three of them
uh when we last spoke i did ask you
about vaccine passports hadn't made up
your mind have you made up your mind
about vaccine passports
so we are looking at
by the end of september when everyone
has had the opportunity to be fully
vaccinated
for
the
large venues venues that um
could
uh
end up you know
causing a real spike in infections um
where we need to use um the
uh certification process and if you look
at what the fa have done they've done so
brilliantly in terms of checking vaccine
status to reopen uh football
that is the sort of right uh thing to do
and we are absolutely um
on track to continue to make sure that
we do that and there's a reason for that
uh trevor the reason being is that
i as does the prime minister want to
make sure the whole economy remains open
the worst thing we can do
for those
venues is to have a sort of open shut
open shut um
strategy because we see infection rates
rise because of
the close interaction of people that's
how the virus spreads uh if people are
in close
uh spaces in large numbers we see spikes
appearing uh the best thing to do then
is to work with the industry to make
sure that
they can open safely and sustainably in
the long term and the best way to do
that is to check vaccine status
all right so okay so what i'm hearing
here is two things interestingly
that we will have a certification
process as you describe it what people
refer to as a vaccine passport and that
you
unless something dramatic happens do not
expect another lockdown
well i will do everything in my power
which is why we're working you know
all hours um to make sure we deliver on
the booster program we've had the
interim advice from the jcvi we're
waiting for the cove boost clinical
trials tell us which vaccine is the
vaccine to boost the immunity and
increase the durability of the
protection for people
because we want to make sure we continue
to transition
i hope this virus from pandemic to
endemic status so that we can continue
to enjoy all the things that we want to
enjoy we can continue to have our
economy fully opened
and get life back to as normal as we can
make it as quickly as possible nobody
enjoys by the way in this government
certainly not this prime minister having
restrictions on people's freedoms it
goes against dna of this government to
do that but the yes
from the experience of the past 18
months
i want to come to the dna i want to come
to the dna of this government in a
second um one of the things that will
tell us what kind of government you are
is um
the money what are you gonna do about
the money we spent billions 500 billion
by some estimates staving off the
economic cost of independence and the
chancellor it looks as though he's going
to have to find the money from somewhere
and there's not that much down the back
of the sofa
let's think about the issue of social
care and benefits um
do you know your constituents in
stratford where you are now going to
feel
comfortable about cutting universal
credit for six million people by 20
pounds a week
so i think the the one thing that my
constitution stratford realize is that
the
chancellor and this government
has provided a safety net both in terms
of welfare and the increase
in the welfare spend
to protect the most vulnerable through
the covert uh crises as well as of
course the rest of the economy 407
billion pounds spent uh protecting jobs
uh at one stage i think we were up to
something like 14 million plus people on
furlough
and of course grants to businesses uh
small business uh
loans um
the the uh safety net that i think this
government's provided is one that people
recognize but as people get back to work
as people get back to um uh trying to
make sure that they they are able to get
lives back
it's only right that we you know try and
make sure that we return the system
where it was where it has been
incredibly generous uh all
you know that's not going to be
tremendously uh reassuring to many of
the people that we we've been talking to
uh we were in newcastle uh this week uh
talking to families uh about
this situation many on benefits and so
on
uh
one of the store owners who
serves people
customers
who are on benefits
told us that when the prime minister
said that he knew he's only borrowing
red wall votes he should have grasped
that anything
that is borrowed can be taken back are
you ready to pay the political price on
that
and i think an additional point which is
part of the same question
when are we going to see
the social care plan
and are you going to pay for it through
a one p rise or more on national
insurance
so let's try and sort of unpack some of
that uh trevor
in terms of
the red wall let's take one example and
that is the
uh incredible achievement of ben houchen
in the northeast why has he done so well
uh this is a a conservative mayor who
has really delivered
on the leveling up agenda
in real worlds
and and that was reflected in the result
in
his return
but he's not responsible for this you
are what are you are we going to see a
social care plan
will we pay for it through a rise in
national insurance or are we now going
to see another pledge
broken
by
as in the
uh
the uh
triple triple lock on pensions and uh
your
president not to rise raise taxes
so sorry forgive me i was answering the
first half of your question because you
were talking about your uh the red wall
uh votes that were borrowed and and the
reason uh ben howard was returned was
such a a an overwhelming majority almost
70 percent
of the vote is because of delivery of
real reform whether it be t size airport
or
the port and the ambitions around
manufacturing therefore the renewable
industry the offshore wind industry and
other parts of the renewable
and net zero
huge opportunities that ben houghton has
grasped that is how you deliver uh the
the sort of
those votes coming back
uh by the second half
around social care reform we are
absolutely committed to uh the social
care reform and we will be coming
forward by the end of the year with
those details and when they do uh okay
all right i'll actually come to your
program and discuss them with you